February may be the shortest month of the
year, but that doesn't mean Netflix is skimping
on the new and original programming.
There's a lot to look forward to in February,
from the Netflix original series Altered Carbon
to Duncan Jones' long-awaited sci-fi noir
Mute.
And that's just scratching the surface.
Here's everything coming to Netflix in February
2018, starting with the Netflix originals.
Altered Carbon: Season 1
Richard K. Morgan's series of hard-boiled
futuristic noir novels has a huge following
among science fiction fans, and by the looks
of the teasers Netflix has been releasing,
those fans will have plenty to love about
the upcoming series.
The story follows Takeshi Kovaks, a soldier
whose mind was imprisoned for hundreds of
years.
"How long have I been down?"
"250 years."
In the future, he's awoken and given a new
body to solve a murder, kicking off a series
of events that leads him deep into a web of
conspiracy.
Altered Carbon is definitely going to be one
of the highlights next month, so check it
out on February 2nd.
On Body and Soul
This Hungarian fantasy drama was announced
as one of the contenders for Best Foreign
Language Film at the 2018 Oscars, but Netflix
isn't waiting to see the results before giving
it an exclusive international release on their
service.
The story centers on two strangers who find
out that they've been having eerily similar
dreams every night, so they set out to recreate
those dreams in real life in the hopes of
figuring out what it all means.
The Guardian gave On Body and Soul a glowing
review, calling it a "bizarre and brutal tale
of lovers in the slaughterhouse."
This is definitely one to put on the radar
for February 2nd.
Coach Snoop: Season 1
Starring everyone's favorite D-oh-double-G,
Coach Snoop takes the rapper out of the studio
and onto the forty-yard-line as the coach
of a youth-league football team.
It sounds like the setup for a sports-themed
spinoff of Half Baked, but from the looks
of it, Coach Snoop is taking a long, hard
hit of inspirational drama, focusing on the
real-life stories of at-risk kids fighting
for a future on the gridiron.
There's no comedy here, just a Hail Mary aimed
straight at your heart.
"Y'all ever heard that story of David and
Goliath?
We are David today, y'all understand?"
"Yes coach."
The eight-episode first season kicks off on
February 2.
Queer Eye: Season 1
The reboot of the groundbreaking reality show
Queer Eye for the Straight Guy sees five gay
fashion gurus--the Fab Five, as Netflix describes
them—working with fashion-challenged people
to introduce a little sophistication into
their lives.
"I'd like the Fab Five to help me get out
of my comfort zone."
It's the old show rebooted for the world of
today, with a renewed focus on acceptance
for the LGBTQ community—along with plenty
of handmade guacamole and fabulous beards,
of course.
"Ohh, yes balance, yes symmetry."
Check out Queer Eye when it splashes onto
Netflix on February 7th.
The Ritual
It wouldn't be a good month on Netflix without
a few original horror releases, and The Ritual
fills that quota early.
The story follows four friends on a backpacking
trip through Scandinavia.
They decide to take a shortcut through a dense
forest—which, of course, is the wrong decision.
"Go southwest, through here, we cut the journey
in half."
"What, through the forest?"
The path leads them into a confrontation with
an evil force connected to an ancient Norse
ritual.
The movie starts with a fairly standard premise,
but elevates it with beautiful scenery and
a refreshing self awareness that takes this
a notch above your typical paranormal horror
film.
"Well, this is clearly the house we get murdered
in."
Enter the woods on February 9th.
The Trader
This Netflix original documentary offers a
bleak look into rural life in Eastern Europe,
centering on a man traveling across Georgia
selling knickknacks and second-hand clothes
in exchange for the only currency with any
meaning in a land stricken by poverty and
hunger: potatoes.
The Trader is sure to be an eye-opening experience.
Step outside your comfort zone and queue it
up on February 9.
Fate/Apocrypha: Part 2
The first part of Netflix's original anime
series Fate/Apocrypha was released in 2017
to generally favorable reviews, and the second
part of Season 1 is slated to roll out February
9, completing the first season story arc.
Tune in for part two this winter.
My Next Guest Needs No Introduction With David
Letterman: George Clooney
Late night icon David Letterman teamed up
with Netflix in January 2018 for the first
installment of his new interview series, which
saw Letterman sitting down with former president
Barack Obama for an hour-long interview about
politics and beards.
"You and I are the same age."
"He's got this biblical beard."
"Do you have a staff?"
Unlike most of its shows, Netflix is releasing
this series one episode at a time, and the
next one will feature George Clooney in the
guest's seat.
Take a look on February 9th.
Seeing Allred
Netflix is chiming in on the wave of allegations
that permeated the news in 2017 with Seeing
Allred, a documentary following activist attorney
Gloria Allred.
As a lawyer, Allred has represented multiple
clients involved in lawsuits against famous
celebrities, and is a vocal opponent of discrimination.
See the documentary on February 9th.
When We First Met
Starring Adam Devine from Workaholics, When
We First Met is a comedy fantasy about a guy
who found the girl of his dreams… and then
blew his chance with her.
Three years later, he gets the chance to go
back in time to the night he messed everything
up to try and fix things.
Queue it up on February 9.
Greenhouse Academy: Season 2
This high school series debuted its first
season in 2017 and follows two twin teenagers
who enroll at a futuristic boarding school.
Unfortunately, there's some kind of global
conspiracy in the works, and it's up to them
to stop it before the evil masterminds can
destroy the earth.
Also, there's a bunch of teen drama and whatnot.
"What is this the fourth grade, or something?"
If you're over the age of, say, 14, there
probably isn't a whole lot here for you, but
if you're a 12-year-old girl, you might just
find your new favorite show.
Season 2 lands on February 14.
Love Per Square Foot
Touted as the first mainstream Indian film
to be released by Netflix on a global scale,
Love Per Square Foot is a romantic comedy
about a man and a woman who decide to get
married so that they can afford an apartment
in Mumbai.
It's bound to be an interesting experience,
if nothing else.
Check it out on February 14.
Re:Mind: Season 1
This Japanese series starts with 11 classmates
who wake up in a locked room with no idea
how they got there.
The more clues they uncover about their situation,
the deeper the threat to their lives appears
to be.
Figure out the mystery when Re:Mind lands
on February 15.
First Team: Juventus
This documentary mini-series tags along with
the stars of the Italian football team Juventus
as they kick their way through the grueling
2017-2018 season.
First Team promises to go behind the scenes
with the team to reveal their lives both on
and off the field.
If you're a fan of the black and white, check
out the first three episodes on February 16.
Everything Sucks!: Season 1
Move over, '80s nostalgia—there's a new
decade in town.
Everything Sucks follows a high school A/V
club in 1996, when VCRs, Discmans, and iron-on
backpack patches reigned supreme."
If you miss the days when Alanis Morissette
and the Goo Goo Dolls were the soundtrack
for everything, check out the first season
of Everything Sucks! on February 16.
You might regret it, but that would just mean
the show really nailed what the '90s were
all about.
The Joel McHale Show with Joel McHale
You may recognize Joel McHale from the long-running
NBC show Community or from his E! series The
Soup—or any of the long list of movies and
shows where he's inevitably played a horrible,
morally bankrupt person.
"I can pick up this pencil, tell you its name
is Steve and go like this --- and part of
you dies, just a little bit on the inside."
On February 18th, McHale lands on Netflix
with The Joel McHale Show with Joel McHale,
a ridiculously named show that will see McHale
going back to his sketch talk show roots,
green screen and all.
Can we say McHale any more?
FullMetal Alchemist
Don't get too excited about a Netflix-produced
version of the classic anime FullMetal Alchemist—this
is a rebranding of the 2017 live-action adaptation
produced in Japan, a film that wasn't particularly
well received by critics.
If you haven't seen it yet, you can form your
own opinion when the movie premieres on Netflix
on February 19th.
The Frankenstein Chronicles: Seasons 1 and
For residents of the UK, The Frankenstein
Chronicles might already be a familiar show.
The series stars Sean Bean as a detective
in the 1800s who's on the trail of a madman
who may or may not be Dr. Frankenstein.
Netflix picked up the acclaimed horror mystery
series in December 2017 for global release
and rebranded it as a Netflix original.
Tune in when both seasons hit on February
20th.
Seven Seconds: Season 1
After a tragic, racially charged accident
involving a black teenager in New York City,
one family fights to prevent a bureaucratic
cover-up in this harrowing crime thriller.
Seven Seconds stars Regina King and Clare-Hope
Ashity.
Take a look when the first season lands on
February 23.
Marseille: Season 2
Netflix's French-language political thriller
Marseille hasn't made a ton of waves yet,
but fans of the show have been hoping for
a second season ever since the first one debuted
in 2016.
The show centers on the mayor of Marseille
as he squares off against his successor and
rival, and it offers plenty of political intrigue
and bureaucratic backstabbing.
It's a touch formulaic, but it should satisfy
any political thriller buff on the hunt for
a bingeable House of Cards replacement.
Catch the second season on February 23.
Mute
Director Duncan Jones has been working on
this film for over a decade, and the wait
is finally over on February 23rd.
In a near-future Berlin, a mute bartender
forges a path through the city's twisted underbelly
on a quest to find his missing girlfriend.
Alexander Skarsgard stars, with Paul Rudd
and Justin Theroux in supporting roles.
Ugly Delicious
Get your forks ready, because there's a brand
new food and culture show on the horizon.
Ugly Delicious dives into on-the-street cuisine
with chef David Chang.
Rude waiters?
Dirty bathrooms?
In Ugly Delicious, it doesn't matter as long
as the food is good.
Take the trip on February 23rd.
Derren Brown: The Push
Illusionist Derren Brown is known for his
controversial shows and psychological experiments,
and Derren Brown: The Push is bound to be
an interesting addition to the performer's
line-up.
Most of the details regarding the show are
being kept quiet, so we'll all have to wait
until February 27 to find out where Derren
Brown takes us next.
Original stand-up comedy
Netflix has been loading up on stand-up specials
in the past couple months, but the streaming
service is only bringing three new specials
into the fold in February.
Kavin Jay: Everybody Calm Down!
Was originally slated for a January release,
but has since been pushed back to February
2nd.
On February 6, you can tune in to Fred Armisen:
Standup For Drummers, and February 27th will
see comedian and actor Marlon Wayans' hour-long
stand-up special, Woke-ish.
That covers all the Netflix originals coming
in February.
Now here are all the other movies and TV shows
arriving next month.
New Movies
February is going to be a great month to relive
the action classics of the past.
Quentin Tarantino's Kill Bill Volumes 1 and
2 will both be arriving on the first of the
month, along with 3000 Miles to Graceland,
to name a few.
For more dramatic fare, Netflix is doubling
down on their gangland classics with Martin
Scorsese's Goodfellas.
That arrives on the first of the month, along
with the Ocean's Eleven trilogy and the 2008
Oscar-winner The Hurt Locker.
And if those don't get the Valentine's mood
rolling, Netflix is rolling out every unromantic
comedy it can get its hand on.
The first of the month is heralding five American
Pie movies, along with Meet the Parents, and
it's sequel with the funny name, and John
C. Reilly's irreverent, musical saga Walk
Hard: The Dewey Cox Story.
"Two things you need to know.
I'm the king, and number two is LOOK OUT MAN!
Look at that!"
And speaking of music, February 1st will also
see some great new documentary releases, like
How the Beatles Changed the World.
Later in the month, look for Winnie, a 2017
documentary about Winnie Mandela, activist
and former wife of Nelson Mandela.
That premieres on February 26.
Perhaps mercifully, Netflix is only adding
two family films in February.
Less mercifully, one of them is The Emoji
Movie, one of the most soul-crushingly bad
animated films in history.
You can look forward to that on February 8th.
Ella Enchanted also arrives on the first of
the month.
After the kids go to bed, turn off the lights
and enjoy Netflix's new thriller lineup.
Look for Scream 3 on the 1st, the 2016 Cabin
Fever remake on the 2nd, Blood Money on the
17th, and Dismissed on the 19th.
Finally, February 24th sees the arrival of
Jeepers Creepers 3.
New television
Fans of thrilling television will have a lot
to look forward to come February.
On the first of the month, Season 4 of Z Nation
arrives, followed by Season 1 of Valor 5 days
later, and Season 1 of The Imposters the following
day on February 7th.
After that, keep an eye out for the thrilling
fifth and final season of Bates Motel on the
20th.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!